like i said gratitude
uh to bill maher and the whole and the
whole team there
um i'd also like to offer an apology um
why
exactly did i not answer his question i
know why you didn't answer this question
you do and you could answer this you
know we'll talk about this just a little
bit so
um bill asked me a few times uh if i
wouldn't be more comfortable taking the
astrazeneca vaccine
than either of them rna vaccines and the
fact is he knows the answer to this
because we ourselves have discussed this
on i think it was episode 58 an episode
that we devoted to
largely to talking about the different
vaccines and and
um what the various risks of them were
um i didn't respond directly um
either either or any of the times i'm
not sure if he asked me two or three
times
um and here's why so you know the fact
is
yes the answer is yes i would uh prefer
to take the astrozenic vaccine to either
the mrna vaccines that are currently on
on the market um
why not because astrazeneca is a
traditional vaccine
it's not but it has a more traditional
a more established delivery mechanism
than the mrna vaccines do so what that
means is it's not a traditional
it's not traditional vaccine it does not
have an attenuated
actual virus associated with it right
it's actually a dna vaccine and the mrna
vaccines are obviously rna vaccines
what it has though is an adenovirus
associated with it which is
its delivery vehicle and
and there are a number of gene therapies
that have used adenoviruses
in the past um there have it's been
fewer and more recently that they've
been begun to be used
uh in vaccines there's a an ebola
vaccine
that's beginning to use it uh we have a
visit from one of our podcats you guys
may see shortly um
so the adenovirus delivery mechanism
is somewhat new but adenoviruses have
been
part of the human
selective experience or our evolutionary
environment
for presumably millions of years whereas
the way that the mrna vaccines get into
you and the cells is they're coded in
what are called lipid nanoparticles lnps
and so you'll sometimes see
them called mrna-lnp vaccines
and um and those are brand new
to the human evolutionary environment we
just we simply have no history with them
and they might work they might be
awesome we're like
everyone who makes any sense is praying
that they are hoping that they are
thinking
these mrna vaccines might be the future
of vaccine technology because one of the
things they have going for them is they
have
very rapid development possibilities as
we saw with these two
but because the lnps the
lipidanoparticles are
brand new to human to
the human evolutionary environment we
just can't know yet and so the risk
seems
higher so that's why i didn't answer
your question directly
bill and i apologize for it but yes i
prefer the astrazeneca vaccine
all right so this actually brings us
back to the thought experiment
great and uh we will link the two up
here so you recall the thought
experiment is you walk into a building
there's a gun on the table you pick it
up put it to your head pull the trigger
and it goes click
now was your behavior safe no
obviously not that's an incredibly
reckless thing to do were you
harmed no you weren't harmed so when we
say that something is unsafe we
are talking we are including the
question of
uncertainty about harms that may come
from something
and so the question about the various
vaccines
comes down to harms we know about
because they have shown up
in the phase three trials
and harms that are emerging in what's uh
referred to as phase four which is where
we are now where
a large population is being vaccinated
and we're tracking
events that may or may not be related to
those vaccines
but what we don't know is anything about
what happens three years down the road
five years down the road
there may be nothing there may be
something and
frankly it could go either way
so the point is there's a lot to say
knowing nothing about the long-term
implications of these things
would you bet that a vaccine that is
built
out of a viral delivery mechanism that
is similar to viruses that human beings
have been dealing with
for probably as you say millions of
years
or would you go with something where the
delivery mechanism is entirely novel we
have no evolutionary history
with it and so no information about how
the body deals with it now it could be
and there are reasons i could make the
argument why
the mrna vaccines stand a chance of
being safer in the long run
they don't interact with the nucleus a
lot is going to come down to differences
in the cell nucleus
right so the mrna is delivered by these
lipid nanoparticles into the cytoplasm
of the cell where the ribosomes then
translated into
spike protein which then shows up to the
immune system effectively it gets
displayed on the surface of the
cells in which the vaccine has entered
and the immune system recognizes it as
foreign which is how
vaccines work go on i have one more
thing to say about this
okay um so it is possible that the
uh bypassing the nucleus has some
benefits
it is essentially certain that there
will be
different affinity for different cell
types between the different vaccines and
that may have a lot to say about what
risks do and do not exist
down down the road from here but the
basic point is we are stuck in the
present
with no information about the long-term
impacts of any of these vaccines
we have some basis to guess on the
adenovirus vaccines
we have no basis to guess for the mrna
vaccines and so given that
if you had to pick what would you do
this is a relatively simple question
it's basic precautionary principle right
you prefer the technology or solution
that's been around for longer
all else being equal and you know
there's a ton not equal here but
insofar as we can tease away all the
other variables
there are some clear ways in which the
astrazeneca vaccine
has a more established history its
elements have a more established history
in
the human body right and so if you think
now back to this little thought
experiment and the conclusion that
putting a gun to your head and pulling
the trigger
is definitely unsafe but not necessarily
harmful
therefore safety is about risk then the
question is well what is the risk
now the harms could go the other way for
there's so much complexity here that
they're
there it's very easy we could put
together a dozen scenarios in which
the actual harm that we would know about
10 years 20 years down the road
would go the other way if it shows up at
all so the problem is it's very hard to
get
all of that nuance into a very tight
discussion in the context of something
like
uh um conversations yeah um
so i guess actually one more thing as
long as we're talking once again about
vaccines
which is not mostly where we're gonna
we're gonna spend time today
um it occurred to me actually when we
were down in l.a before we went on
real time last night you know you and i
were both reading up
some more on some of the literature
that's out there and
you know what something that many people
will have heard is that both the phis
and the moderna vaccines
need to be stored at extremely low
temperatures
and most people will not have stopped to
consider why that might be
in part maybe in in entirety at least in
large part it's because rna is very
very susceptible to decay and that you
can basically stall the decay out by
keeping it in you know it's such low
temperatures that it can't
but not only is it susceptible to decay
but once it gets into the um the space
between the cells in the body
you have ribonucleases all over this all
over the place
that are just waiting primed to destroy
rna
and so this um the lipid nanoparticle
coding the vaccine is basically a way
to sneak the rna past the inter
intercellular space into the cells and
what what all of that means one of the
implications i think and i don't think
i've seen this anywhere else
is that if there is an error in
um in transportation
in storage and taking too long after
you've taken out of the freezer and
gotten it into your arm um it is likely
actually i would think that these
vaccines actually lose efficacy
and so you are going to get something
close to a binary situation of
this vaccine is either as effective as
it can be and it might even this might
mean that it's actually
the our mrna vaccines are actually
really close to 100 effective
because what you have sometimes is a
failure to keep the vaccine cold enough
such the rna is already completely
degraded by the time it gets into you
such that it's not effective at all
and so what you might expect with the
mrna vaccines is a prediction i'm making
is extremely high variance actually that
you don't have that you will be less
likely
to have um some protection within an
individual
rather you would have like this worked
because the vaccine did what it was
supposed to because it was kept at the
storage
in the storage way that it was required
to
or it wasn't and therefore it was just
getting a placebo
effectively well so i don't see any
reason
to expect a binary i agree with your
prediction
about the variance but in effect
there's some threshold we're shooting
for ideally with a virus you want to see
cellular immunity emerge that is to say
t cells that are responsive in this case
to the spike protein
that is being encoded by the mrnas
that we're delivering to the cells you
want to see t cells that react to it
that would tend to give you a good
lasting immunity which is of course the
objective of the vaccine
and so there's a question about how much
of how much of the mrna has to actually
survive to get into cytoplasm to be
displayed to the immune system
to get that response there will be
individual variation there will be
individual variation
for reasons that probably have to do
with variation in individual immune
systems there's also going to be a
certain amount of luck which cells
actually get reached by this you know
this
slurry that's going to be injected into
people it's going to hit some cells
and it's going to enter them and how
well it is displayed to the immune
system
will matter i also wonder how this
interacts
with um prior exposure to covet right
so the fact that this spike protein is
something that some immune systems will
have seen and some immune systems will
not have seen
raises questions so anyway i would
expect
a lot of variance and um the
degradation basically if you know just
simple chemistry tells us that if
the low temperatures are necessary in
order to keep these molecules
viable in order that they make it into
the cells that
those that have been kept out of the
freezer too long and we've heard
multiple stories now of uh you know uh
what's the word uh some uh
group of vials uh is warming up and
vaccines are delivered to people so they
don't go bad but you would imagine that
there would be intermediate cases
and what will those look like and how
will we recognize them
uh in in a data set yeah now in this
case i would
i would not imagine um that as they
warmed up that they would become
dangerous they're just going to become
not effective uh i agree first pass i'd
guess the same
but i'd love to know and uh you know
hopefully hopefully what happens is they
the
um stray mrnas do just get uh
chewed up in the normal course of the
the
interstitial space being being cleared
so um
for those of you new here our producers
our 16 year old son zach
zack can you show my screen do we have
that capability at this point cool
so i just want to read one paragraph
this is a paper in
actually this is a a news article in the
journal nature biotechnology
which is one of the nature group
journals from the end of november 2020
which was at that point
a perspective imagining looking forward
and saying what are the vaccines that
are likely to be out there and how do
they compare what are the risks
this is actually an excellent paper and
i'll put it in the show notes
but i just want to read one paragraph
from it which i've highlighted here we
go
still much about the vaccine's efficacy
and safety
and st here she's talking about the mrna
vaccines in particular
still much about the vaccine's efficacy
and safety biological details that could
shape the course of the vaccine's impact
on containing the pandemic
remain unknown quote personally i'm
waiting for further data concerning
t-cell responses and duration of the
antibodies says stanley plotkin a
pioneering vaccinologist
and former pharmaceutical executive who
now consults for vaccine manufacturers
and while acknowledging that the data
report data are quote very encouraging
plotkin is reserving judgment on the
mrna vaccines until more results become
available from late stage trials of the
many other experimental vaccines
now moving their way through clinical
development later in this news article
i believe it's him who says by the end
of next year meaning at that point by
the end of 2021
we should have enough data um to
actually compare
both um you know efficacy and safety at
least through you know a year-ish
of the various the various vaccine
platforms
that people are now getting throughout
the world and you know he as
everyone should be is very much looking
forward to seeing what those data look
like
yeah i think um it's important we've
already seen
some changes of course uh for example
cautions about pregnant women not
getting vaccines
that uh yeah although on that one yep
um so the the
who and the cdc seemed to be in
disagreement they were
and now they've both they've both gone
back to the party line they're both
saying
there's no reason to think that the
vaccines uh should
uh should harm pregnant women now as far
as i know
they haven't those trials don't exist
they're just sort of
saying again we don't think it's going
to be harmful
i would be i would be very cautious yeah
i was pregnant
about getting anywhere near a very newly
developed vaccine
yeah i agree and you know it cuts both
ways uh covet is liable to be
uh consequential for pregnancy so you
know we've got to be even more careful
about
lockdown and and masks and social
distancing
yeah yeah so we are not we are in a very
tough puzzle effectively
we are all guinea pigs in a couple of
experiments running in parallel one
having to do with vaccines the other
having to do
um with this novel virus and
it is very difficult to juggle the
competing
hazards and there are clearly short-term
very large hazards that come with
uh coming down with covid and then we
have to compare that to all of the
unknowns over in vaccine space and
it's not an enviable position we find
ourselves in